[Music]
as we race toward more sophisticated
forms of virtual reality it's worth
considering the work of Stanley Kubrick
who spent his career probing and solving
the questions of immersive storytelling
in ways that still remain unique more
than any other director it's easy to
imagine Kubrick's films as worlds that
we could explore as games or even
virtual reality rides where we've glide
through narrative spaces intensely
involved but never in control this is
because Kubrick was as much concerned
with the way audiences engaged with his
movies as he was with the ideas that
they were trying to convey in fact for
Kubrick these two things were
inseparable
linked we often think of Kubrick as a
highly stylized director which he was
but crucially Kubrick never lets us
forget what the purpose of style
actually is style is a lens that gives
the viewer a point of access to the
material it's about the audience not the
director something that new filmmakers
should keep in mind today I want to take
a closer look at Eyes Wide Shut
Kubrick's final film and the ways it
immerses us in the story of Alice and
especially dr. bill Harford a married
couple going through a difficult time in
their relationship this isn't the first
film to deal with subjects of love or
sex infidelity or even secret cults the
Kubrick is intent on making our
engagement with these things one of a
kind how does he do that well the first
and most noticeable aspect of Eyes Wide
Shut is definitely it's strange
pacing it's a slow moving on the level
of narrative but especially in the
dialogue listening to Tom Cruise and
Nicole Kidman speak is like watching a
dripping faucet every word drops out of
their mouths with the same lifeless
rhythm look
women don't they basically just don't
think like that
if you see exhaustion in their faces and
hear it in their voices that's because
they really were exhausted Kubrick made
his actors do countless takes of every
scene including the ones where they had
to break down and cry this is the reason
why eyes wide shut holds the Guinness
record for the longest movie shoot ever
but it's also the reason that these
utterly unique performances something
beyond tired beyond giddy that state of
dreamy detachment Kubrick was going for
[Music]
now this accomplishes two things first
it adds to the hypnotic tone of the film
Eyes Wide Shut is based on a novella
called dream story and the film
certainly plays out like a dream or a
drugged up hallucination and second the
detached performances serve to block the
lead characters from being targets of
the viewers empathy that makes for a
really interesting combination let me
explain why from the moment bill leaves
the house after Alex gives a long
wounding speech about her fantasy of
sleeping with another man the narrative
conspires across a series of
increasingly sexualized encounters too
deeply involve you in the unfolding
events first a patient's daughter
confesses her love to bill then bill
hires a prostitute then building to an
old friend at a cafe who tells him about
a secret sex party later that night then
at a costume shop after-hours bill
witnesses the owners young daughter
sleeping with two businessmen and
finally bill arrived at the sex party
which is much more intense than he
anticipated all this time you're
experiencing the night from the
perspective of Bill but not from a
position of empathy or even sympathy for
that matter instead the viewer engages
in what philosopher Alessandro
Giovanelli calls experiential
identification in which the result of
occupying Bill's perspective while not
empathizing with him is that the
perspective becomes your own it's really
as if the viewer is playing a virtual
reality game of Eyes Wide Shut
this explains why we react to the orgy
sequence with such intensity Kubrick
leads us down beat by beat to this
moment with precision
we've been pulled so far into the dream
that the simple act of bill putting on
his mask erasing his identity completely
is for the viewer a moment of deeper
immersion than the best VR
[Music]
from that moment on the experience of
the party is as much ours as it is
Bill's there are plenty of things that
Kubrick does visually here to draw you
in as he does in his other movies like
using wide-angle lenses or switching to
POV shots most of which are
unfortunately too explicit for me to
show but what sets Eyes Wide Shut apart
is this systematic effort to swap you in
for the protagonist this is what the
whole movie visuals narrative dialogue
and character works together to
accomplish the masked ball orgy scene
takes place exactly halfway through the
movie but you're captured in its world
for the remaining hour what exactly
happened how did you let yourself get in
so deep your questions are the same as
Bills and as the two of you attempt to
piece together the answers like a dream
half remembered nothing comes up clearer
bill can't reach his patients daughter
you can't find his friend Nick
nightingale and when he goes back to the
home of the prostitute she's gone even
at the costume shop things have
completely changed nothing quite makes
sense you were going to call police
whoa thanks James the information that
you can piece together tells a story
that's dark and haunting I noticed mr.
Nightingale had a bruise on his cheek
and to be perfectly honest I also looked
at it then at the end Sydney [__]
suddenly appears again mirroring his
appearance at the beginning of the film
as an authoritative voice to offer an
explanation that paints a more innocent
picture you just might have the wrong
idea about one or two things
you know Kubrick died only a few days
after completing the final edit of Eyes
Wide Shut by that time in his career a
lot of people had written and said a lot
of things about his work people are
still doing it I'm doing it right now
but the viewer is who Kubrick cared
about most and he or she stands were
Bill Harford stands in between the
artists and tension
critics interpretation and the actual
experience of the movie itself Eyes Wide
Shut I think is an ode to the experience
to the raw impression of seeing
something marvelous Kubrick drags you
into the movie Plan C at its centre and
challenges you to figure out what
happened he was a stylist but his style
was for us he made some of the best
movies of all time but more importantly
he taught us how to watch them
[Music]
everybody thank you so much for watching
this episode was brought to you by
Squarespace if you want to make a
website you want to be a really easy
process Squarespace has some beautiful
award-winning designer templates to
choose from that makes the process
really simple it's got 24-hour customer
service no upgrades nothing to install
no patches ever and making your domain
names is really easy you can start your
free trial at squarespace.com and if you
use the offer code nerdwriter you can
get 10% off your first purchase really
simple way to make a website thanks guys
I'll see the rest of you next Wednesday